et analyse on va plus loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui
anne-Élisabeth Moutet d'historialiste à
Paris du délit Telegraphe bonjour
anne-Élisabeth face à vous Bruno Darroux
chroniqueur international de France 24
bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël l'eau et
l'électricité coupée ce soir à Kiev la
capitale ukrainienne qui a été à nouveau
le théâtre de bombardements comme le
reste du pays environ 70 missiles de
croisière tirés par la rue si affirment
les autorités ukrainiennes conséquences
volodymer zellenski demande une réunion
d'urgence du Conseil de sécurité écoutez
le décret la situation
sujet de l'approvisionnement en
électricité et en eau tous les
ingénieurs travaillent à résoudre le
problème la tâche a été confiée aux
autorités locales nous rétablirons tout
cela et nous traverserons tout cela
parce que nous sommes un peuple
incassable
allez bombardement rue Saint contre le
système énergétique ukrainien qui
provoque même des pannes jusqu'en
Moldavie le doute n'est plus permis à
anne-Élisabeth la Russie est déterminée
à plonger cette partie de l'Europe dans
le froid et dans le noir pour l'hiver
oui je ne savais pas qu'il y avait un
doute d'ailleurs parce que ça fait un
certain temps qu'ils essayent et parfois
ils réussissent il y a eu un discours il
y a trois semaines à peu près de deux
Hélène ski enfin un discours c'est bon
il s'adresse tous les jours à la
population et il a dit vous pensez que
vous pouvez nous casser
nous si nous avons le choix entre être
sans eau et sans vous ce sera sans vous
sans électricité ou sans vous ce sera
sans vous sans chaleur ou sans vous ce
sera sans vous et c'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que le Parlement
ukrainien continue de siéger que les
Ukrainiens se manifestent que la
population est derrière lui absolument
on voit tous les comptes Twitter on voit
toutes les déclarations on voit les
vidéos prises par des téléphones un peu
n'importe où et on voit que la
population est dernières Hélène ski
c'est un changement de stratégique quand
même dans de la part de la Russie dans
cette guerre mono un changement de
stratégie je sais pas parce que ça fait
déjà quand même plusieurs semaines que
que les rues sont recours assez
bombardements un peu massif contre alors
au départ contre des des cibles c'est
indistinctement
contre des cibles énergétiques
fournisseurs de l'énergie alors il
continue mais c'est un peu plus tous
azimut alors changement de stratégie
est-ce que c'est parce que la Russie
voit qu'elle a des grosses difficultés
sur le terrain notamment autour de
Carson en particulier qu'elle se dit que
bon bah au moins ils peuvent bombarder
et puis c'est une stratégie sur sur
l'hiver pour essayer de briser le moral
de la population civile qui va quand
même je pense vivre un hiver quand même
particulièrement rigoureux dans les
conditions très dures mais effectivement
comme vous le disiez pour le moment la
population
ukrainienne reste soudée derrière son
président et cet effet là ne se produit
pas mais ça veut pas dire pour autant
que les Russes vont arrêter pour autant
malheureusement non il y a une maternité
a même été détruite aujourd'hui à
zaporigènes tu as un nourrisson c'est
dans ce contexte que le Parlement
européen lui adopte une résolution elle
qualifie la Russie d'État promoteur du
terrorisme simple symbole anne-Élisabeth
je ne pense pas je pense que ça veut
dire que automatiquement la Russie se
trouve maintenant sur des listes qui
sont bon les listes de sanctions ça
existe déjà mais qui peuvent être
réutilisés par d'autres d'autres
assemblées internationales par des des
assemblées des décors spécialistes de la
Commission européenne et aussi
évidemment le but c'est de le faire
prendre en compte par les Nations unies
la dernière question c'est est-ce que
veulent les Ukrainiens c'est que les
Nations Unies ont été fondées en 1945
précisément pour répondre à à aux
attaques qu'on venait de vivre pendant 6
ans avec la deuxième guerre mondiale et
que la Russie a hérité du du poste de du
siège permanent au Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies
il y en a que 5 des sièges permanents au
Conseil de sécurité et maintenant là on
dit on ne peut pas avoir un état qui
viole tous les principes sur lesquels
les Nations Unies ont été fondées et
l'idée consiste à faire sortir la Russie
au minimum du Conseil de sécurité et
même à en faire un état voyou qui puisse
sortir des Nations Unies alors c'est pas
encore fait le Conseil de sécurité c'est
pas impossible puisque même bah là
écoutez il y a le tard cette partie du
problème puisqu'il Yalta ça consiste à
dire il y a tout un tas de gens des
Polonais des moldavres et hongrois tout
ça ces gens-là ne comptent pas c'est pas
important on va laisser les Russes
continuer à faire ce qu'ils font depuis
les années 20 c'est-à-dire une dictature
sanguinaire on a tout de même lu sur le
génétique et puis on divise le monde et
ben maintenant les gens qui étaient dans
ce monde divisés qui ont été libérés à
partir du moment de la chute du Perlin
disent mais nous autres les Polonais les
Estoniens les Baltes les les enfin les
gens d'Europe centrale et de de l'Est
nous méritons la liberté au Tang
d'autres un certain nombre de ces pays
ont rejoint
Union européenne se sont astreints à une
modernisation de leur économie et à de
la législation anticorruption qui a fait
faire des progrès l'ukrain elle-même a
un procureur qui s'occupe des questions
de corruption depuis bien avant la
guerre mais qui continue à travailler
pendant toute la guerre justement parce
qu'ils veulent être dans les rails de
l'entrée dans l'Europe qui prennent sa
treize au sérieux et donc d'un côté vous
avez des peuples qui disent on nous a
fait ça une fois mais pas deux fois il
devient juste quand même là pour le
moment c'est juste le Parlement européen
c'est à dire que pour le moment c'est
pas le Conseil européen etc qui a pris
sa décision tire les votes du Parlement
européen c'est important mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas
décisionnaire si je puis dire c'est pour
ça que les anglais sont partis
d'exécution il devient néanmoins avec ce
type de qualification à un niveau disons
officiel en Europe désormais puisque le
Parlement européen représente c'est
quand même l'émanation des peuples
européens du vote des peuples européen
devient quasiment impossible à la vient
de se rapprocher de la Russie
que l'Union européenne est un bien sûr
la Russie on imagine quand même pour
Moscou les montants sans se voir
qualifier de terroristes par le
Parlement européen évidemment ça fait
pas plaisir
les dirigeants russes connaissent
parfaitement le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes et savent très
bien que aussi désagréable que ce soit
qu'il y a un vote en ce sens du
Parlement européen ce n'est pas de même
niveau que s'il est 27 membres du
Conseil européen des annoncé
officiellement qui considérait la Russie
donc ça n'obéit rien pour la suite de
nos possibilités de rapprocher la Russie
n'est pas c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
en soi pour la Russie mais je pense pas
que ça va empêcher de la lumière Poutine
de dormir quand même mais Elisabeth nos
amis russes ont fait une un des
dernières le serveuse c'est à dire
qu'ils ont bloqué le site internet du
Parlement européen avec des attaques si
des cyberattaques qui ont immobilisé
totalement les moyens informatiques du
Parlement alors comme respect de la
démocratie moi je suis pas surprise mais
ils ont souligné à quel point ça les
enduit vous savez à chaque fois le une
bonne partie de la propagande russe
j'allais dire soviétique
[Musique]
la prive ces armées américaines
britanniques françaises de certains
stocks d'armes qui sont quand même assez
stratégiques pour eux en fait c'est ça
la question les elens qui leur dit
surtout continuer surtout n'arrêtait pas
mais il y a un petit débat qui monte
notamment aux États-Unis
comme ça à ce rythme-là quand même ce
soir que la Russie la des indications
sur lesquelles la Russie serait en train
de manquer de munitions anne-Élisabeth
écoutez on a la dernière fois que les
Américains ont fait des déclarations sur
ce qui se passait sur le terrain c'était
juste avant la guerre et ils avaient
prévu comment allait se passer
l'offensive et on les croyait pas donc
j'ai tendance à penser qu'ils sont
relativement bien informés d'autant
qu'il y a une circulation de la des des
des informations
surtout surtout sur toute la région et
que c'est absolument de tous les anciens
voisins de de de la Russie et notamment
des pays baltes des de la Pologne qui
ont des services qui de gens qui
connaissent les russes depuis très
longtemps qui qui travaillent sur la
question je pense que les informations
des Américains sont très bonnes l'autre
chose c'est que
pour le budget américain ce qu'elle ce
qu'on a donné pour lui créer un qui a
l'air énorme qui est plusieurs milliards
de dollars de dollars 40 milliards
d'années
de des États-Unis donc ils ont encore
les moyens mais surtout il y a
maintenant des études qui ont été faites
en particulier par un un fentanque de
qui s'appelle le SEPA et qui travaille
avec le temps et c'est que pour le coup
d'une guerre contre un ennemi parce que
si on a le temps c'est bien parce qu'il
y a un ennemi de l'autre côté si on a
des alliances militaires c'est pas ce
qu'on a un ennemi on n'a pas des armes
uniquement pour les regarder en disant
c'est très joli c'est un musée c'est la
guerre qui coûte le moins cher aux
États-Unis si on veut parler de quelque
chose qui peut avoir leur cynique mais
qui est important les Ukrainiens se
défendent parce que c'est chez eux et
cette existentiel où ils sont là où ils
disparaissent et plus on reprend des des
des villes et des villages et on apprend
que les Russes comment les Russes se
sont comportés et plus les Ukrainiens
sont absolument
chauffer à blanc de rage qu'on ait pu
faire ça au 21e siècle dans un pays qui
demandait rien mais il y a aussi le fait
que dans eux ils vont se battre c'est
pas une question comme j'entends dire
parfois que c'est des proximes bien au
contraire ils se battre parce que c'est
ça ou rien mais il y a manipuler voilà
mais c'est pas instrumentalisé c'est pas
instrumentalisé ou c'est même pas
simplement dire les Américains ont
entraîné les Ukrainiens d'abord c'est
plutôt les Britanniques et puis
entraîner le ukrainien c'est une chose
même une bonne affaire entre guillemets
d'un point de vue militaire et
financière parce que les il y a les
c'est un conflit sur lesquels les armes
sont testées sur lesquelles il y a un
retour d'expérience sur lequel
essentiellement ils ont les Ukrainiens
déjà réduit démoli probablement la
moitié de tout le potentiel militaire
existant russe c'est tout ça qui peut
pas nous attaquer
et ils en ont récupéré beaucoup ils ont
même remercié beaucoup Moscou dans un
petit film assez c'est marrant
en Chine en tout cas parce que là c'est
l'autre un grand adversaire stratégique
des États-Unis là-bas la situation
commence à devenir invivable pour des
millions de personnes non pas à cause
des coupures d'électricité mais des
restrictions liées à la politique dite
du zéro covid alors que les cas
repartent à la hausse apk les images
tournent en boucle sur les réseaux
sociaux celle d'employés la gigantesque
usine village de Junjo un propriétaire
du du géant taïwanais des composantes
électroniques foxcom des milliers
d'entre eux prothèses contre le
confinement qui leur est imposé des
conditions qui décrivent comme
insupportable un dortoir insalubre
manque de nourriture peur des
contaminations c'est tout un système qui
menace de de craquer sous la chape de
plomb chinoise Bruno
en tout cas pour le moment les les
chinois ils ont fait peu de commentaires
il y a eu un la question a été posée au
porte-parole du ministère chinoise de
faire des étrangers
parce que effectivement on s'aperçoit
d'ailleurs que Foxconn qui est donc âgé
en taïwanais emploie au total je crois
un million de personnes en Chine un des
premiers employeurs du secteur privé en
Chine ce qui en dit long quand même sur
parfois les vrais relations entre la
Chine et Taïwan et puis il y a Apple
aussi évidemment qui est concerné
puisque c'est la principale c'est le
principal site de fabrication des iPhone
et Apple pour le moment ne sait pas
exprimer non plus non ce que ça fait
ressurgir c'est-à-dire ces décisions de
confiner des des centaines d'ouvriers
dans des conditions effectivement très
dures depuis un mois et demi et surtout
visiblement si on a bien compris le
Foxton avait promis leur verser une
prime très importante qui finalement
était très très fortement divisé et
c'est ça qui a été un peu la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase ça dit
quoi anne-Élisabeth bouteille un peu le
mur qui est en train de de rencontrer la
politique chinoise arbitraire pyramidale
c'est pas une pierre aussi dans le
jardin des taïwanais d'Apple alors je
pense que si les Taïwanais veulent faire
déménager une partie de leur production
dans d'autres pays d'Asie du Sud-Est
tous les compétences sont en train de
monter y compris au Vietnam c'est
parfaitement possible c'est vrai qu'il y
a des liens entre Taïwan et la Chine et
entre une partie de à la fois de la la
communauté économique chinoise d'une
part et et et et le parti qui est dans
l'opposition en ce moment l'ancien coup
à une Town qui a été celui de shangite
par rapport au
Liban nationalistes qui sont au pouvoir
maintenant mais plus au-delà de ça ça
nous dit quelque chose sur le fait que
le système totalitaire est incapable il
peut être extrêmement puissant on parle
de chape de plomb etc mais je pense
surtout que il n'est incapable d'être
agile et c'est cette agilité qui fait ce
qu'on a réussi en Occident c'est à dire
justement la révolution numérique et
tout ça moi je suis très frappée du sort
qui est fait assez malheureuse ouvriers
de chez Foxton qui sont essentiels à
tellement de points de vue à l'économie
et à l'image de la Chine et on les
traite un petit peu sans évidemment les
envoyer au front ou on les traite comme
les comme les mobilisés de de Poutine
de ces gens qui ont été mobilisés et
ramassés même quand ils n'étaient pas
sur les listes parce qu'il fallait faire
du chiffre qu'on a envoyé sans
équipement sans chaussures sans sans
vêtements avec des des armes cassées et
qu'on a fait dormir par terre ou dans la
littéralement dans la campagne dans le
dans l'automne et l'hiver et c'est la
même chose je veux dire que c'est c'est
de la chair à canon ou c'est de la chair
à microprocesseur mais c'est le même
état d'esprit et c'est quelque chose qui
laisse des qui laissent des traces et
qui qui est en fait la le premier aveu
de fragilité le seul truc qui s'affaire
c'est bon dans le doute on vous colle en
tôle c'est oui problème et puis après il
y a la politique zéro covid quand même
de la Chine en fait qui se qui se
poursuit malgré nous malgré la
grenouille sociale qui monte parce que
là on parle de Foxton mais enfin ça
monte aussi parfois ailleurs
ces sujets mais moi d'après d'après tout
ce que j'ai lu en fait ce n'est pas
simplement parce que c'est des gens
butaient par idéologie etc apparemment
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'ils ont un
peu raté
leur vaccin leur vaccins 1 n'est pas
très efficace parce que c'était une
stratégie assez efficace jusqu'à
l'arrivée des vaccins fin 2020 en fait
ils ont eu moins de jours de confinement
à l'époque que nous ici en Europe mais
leur vaccins alors là par nationalisme
etc ils ont voulu faire leur vaccin qui
a pas été très efficace il y a des
réticences de la population et c'est à
partir de ce moment-là où ils sont
retrouvés dans l'obligation de maintenir
cette politique de zéro militaire
suffisante voilà parce que la population
notamment âgée et finalement mal
vaccinée et il se disent vu l'ampleur de
la population si on ne maintient pas
cette politique s'il y a une nouvelle
vague épidémique là ça aura des
proportions absolument dramatiques
évidemment il refuse évidemment au
vaccin occidental est-ce que j'allais
dire la Chine victime de son
nationalisme vaccinal on a tous failli
être victime des êtres de cynamisme
vaccinal puisqu'en France on a vacciné
plus tard plutôt que de prendre la
strazeneca dans ton disait tellement de
mal mais
malgré tout ça laisse des traces
considérables dans la population il
fallait confiné
j'ai pas d'idéologie sur ça mais on voit
aussi qu'au bout d'un certain temps le
confinement crée des il y a des
séquelles économiques et des séquelles
psychologiques il y a des séquelles à
tout point de vue la Chine est beaucoup
moins bien équipée que nous l'avons été
on peut être content de temps en temps
d'après d'habiter chez nous de se
plaindre et ça veut dire qu'il y a des
enfants sont pas allés à l'école que les
gens sont pas sortis de chez eux tout ça
c'est c'est la réaction et on l'a bien
vu au Congrès récent du Parti communiste
chinois c'est au contraire encore plus
de rigidité je pense pas que la Chine
soit dans un état prérévolutionnaire du
tout la Russie j'ai d'autres questions
mais la Chine je pense pas mais
néanmoins ça ça a des conséquences et on
sait pas encore ce que ça va être mais
ça va être intéressant à regarder merci
beaucoup tous deux c'était on va plus
loin avec anne-Élisabeth Mouté et Bruno
Daru restez sur France 24 prochains
journal dans 3 minutes